Napoleon brought more than half a million men.
The Russian armies refused him the battle he needed.
They retreated instead, and burned the supplies behind them as they went.
It was the largest invasion force assembled in Europe up to that point.
He reached Moscow in September and found something no conqueror plans for.
The city was empty.
Almost the entire population had left.
There was nobody there to surrender to him.
A conqueror needs somebody to accept defeat.
There was nobody left in the building.
That night, fires started in several districts at once.
The city's firefighting equipment had been removed before the French arrived.
Most of the city was still built out of wood.
Over four days, roughly three quarters of Moscow burned.
Whether an order was given, or the fires spread from looting, is argued to this day.
The effect was not ambiguous.
The governor of the city had ordered the fire pumps removed before he left.
Napoleon held the capital and gained nothing from it.
No supplies, no winter shelter, no government to negotiate with.
He waited five weeks for a peace offer that never arrived.
The retreat began in October.
Of the men who marched into Russia, only a small fraction marched out.
The army that had beaten every power in Europe was destroyed by a city that refused to be occupied.
Cold, hunger and constant attack finished what the fire had started.
A century later the empire collapsed from the inside.
Nineteen seventeen brought revolution, and with it a decision that reversed Peter's.
The Bolsheviks moved the capital back to Moscow in nineteen eighteen.
The imperial eagles came down from the Kremlin towers.
Red Square became the stage of a global ideology.
Moscow was now the centre of a state that intended to remake the entire world in its image.
Foreign delegations came to study it, and foreign governments came to fear it.
In the nineteen thirties the eagles were replaced with red stars of ruby glass, lit from inside.
They are still up there, and they still turn in the wind.
And then, for the fourth time in its history, an army came for this city with the stated intention of ending it.
In the autumn of nineteen forty one, German forces advanced to within sight of Moscow.
Some units reached the last tram stop on the edge of the city.
Officers could see the buildings of the city through their field glasses.
The city did not fully evacuate.
Factories kept running.
Civilians dug anti tank ditches by hand, and in December, in extreme cold, the Red Army counterattacked.
The military parade on Red Square went ahead that November, and the troops marched from it directly to the front line.
The advance stopped there permanently.
It was the first major failure of that army, and it happened at the gates of a city that had already survived three burnings.
What followed was construction on an enormous scale.
Wide avenues, a metro built like a palace, and seven towers that still define the skyline.
Much of it was raised by a population that had just lost tens of millions of people.
And in December nineteen ninety one the flag above the Kremlin came down, and the state that had built all of it ceased to exist, almost overnight.
Moscow absorbed that too.
Today it holds more than twelve million people, and the towers of its financial district stand a few kilometres from walls raised in the fourteen hundreds.
The two sit inside the same skyline, and neither one looks out of place.
Look at the whole sequence at once and the pattern is hard to miss.
Burned by the Mongols.
Burned by the Tatars.
Occupied by the Poles.
Burned again in eighteen twelve.
Besieged in nineteen forty one.
Five times destroyed or nearly taken.
Five times rebuilt, on the same hill, above the same river, by people who kept deciding the position was worth the risk.
That is not really a story about empire.
It is a story about a decision made over and over, usually by ordinary people standing in ash, choosing to start again.
Moscow was never inevitable.
It was rebuilt.
Thank you for watching, and if you want the next chapter of this history, tell us in the comments where to go next.